right we're doing something totally
wonderful and insane watching ghost
outdoors I and everybody else went and
took pottying classes and little did we
know what an aphrodisiac that would
become I have a friend who used to work
for Jimmy Carter and she used to give
after they suck screen ghosts at the
White House they gave potting lessons in
I guess a basement room in the White
House I hope that was incredible it's
the first and only time in my entire
life that when I read the script I could
actually hear Whoopi Goldberg's voice in
my head and I mean we had never worked
with Jerry before and Janet and I came
in to meet the sort of audition for the
part of the casting director as one does
and I said to him have you already hired
Whoopi Goldberg he said well we've
thought about her but i'd like to see
who else there is i went really high
she's like I thought she was born to
play the part and so months and months
and months went by and we met fabulous
actresses and after the actress Jerry
would say she was very good but I don't
think that's it and I would say so what
about what we called her good he would
say all right well let's you know she's
there and I think she'd like to do this
but let's keep looking and we met over I
met over 200 actresses and of those 200
I think Jerry probably met somewhere in
the neighborhood of 60 or 70 actresses
and then finally finally finally when
Patrick was hired Jerry said to Patrick
what do you think about what we go over
q SI pensa great idea and Jerry said
yeah
I think I came out here and screen
tested and I remembered having an
argument with jerry zucker the director
at my screen test because he said I need
you to play it more like dr. like more
edge more like you know it cannot a good
guy I said no it's totally not the way
to do it because you need to win the
audience's trust I may need to believe
in me and then they'll feel doubly
betrayed and that's how you'll really it
really will work and and he said well
yeah I know either watching of life in
prison but they won't want you to be
dead and just until we have this big
debate about it and I I stuck to my guns
and got part as we screen every Gus may
ever made and we're trying to figure out
what would be the best methodology
visually for Patrick going through solid
objects and I remember Walter Murch our
brilliant editor saying it should be
like an ink blotter and we were saying
incline people remain ink water he said
well you know when you put ink on the
water it absorbs it and so that's how
that came about ILM did a wonderful job
of taking that notion and when Patrick
touches the wall is
body his skin is absorbed like a neat